speaking of shutting things down can we
talk about
facebook shutting me down and my suing
them
facebook shut you down
i
i did a piece on is
global warming really a horrible crisis
got 24 million views on facebook
and now they won't show it to anybody
because they hire these fact checkers
from the pointer institute this leftist
group
which is i think run by the saint
petersburg
paper here in florida
and
they justify it
by saying well our fact checkers found
your story incomplete
well it's
a five-minute tv piece of course it's
incomplete
and the fact checkers say it's wrong
because stossel said this they put
what they say i said in quotes
and it's not what i said they took a
quote from someone else or made it up
and when we point this out
they don't change it they're lying about
me
and so far in the court case that one
headline that you just put up
they said well our fact checkers
are really just opinions so you can't
sue us
but they call them fact checks
former fox business uh host john stossel
soon facebook alleging that the social
media company one that's control
contract the fact checking organization
defaming him when it flagged
two of his videos alerting viewers to
missing contacts and partly false claims
the lawsuit also claims that stasso's
professional reputation has been
significantly and irreparably damaged by
the false labels and statements since
estacio lefox business he's been
releasing videos on various social
platforms including facebook instagram
youtube and the endeavor has apparently
been somewhat lucrative has made around
ten thousand dollars a month from
facebook alone my news model is based on
social media our company's showing you
videos he he said on facebook but when
facebook fact check and label appeared
on two video stats alleges that his ad
revenue
from the platform was cut by 45
interesting so uh is this done with is
it still going is it still or still
going these cases take a while and i
don't care about the revenue but we
facebook used to be my main outlet in
reaching millions of people now it's
youtube because once these idiot fact
checkers facebook just gives up
the power to them
we don't like this we think climate
change is a bigger crisis than you
implied so you can't say it
are you friends with dennis prager
i
just like what he does we're not
personal friends you guys have never
spoken
years back
no on the reason i ask i'm not trying to
find a conspiracy between the two of you
i'm just saying like he he sued youtube
and they had a
issue that they went back and forth i
don't know if he's talking to him his
wife yeah but
it was
a lot of good information came out of
him losing the rest of us learned a lot
from it i don't know if uh may not be a
bad idea for the two of you guys to
speak so their argument really was that
you
didn't necessarily
uh you know uh misrepresent just it was
a quote and the whole story wasn't given
so because of that we got to take this
24 million view video down
uh
they
basically three
oh it's something 40 million a real
number by the way on facebook facebook
of course 24 million down to zero who's
the facebook guy that you interviewed
the facebook fast checker yeah yeah he
was a fact he was not a fact checker he
was not a fact checker moderator
moderator he looked at yeah he looked at
things that they would take down and
things that they wouldn't take down and
that revealed a lot he was a guy that
worked for facebook
telling us some of the systems and
uh the guy got emotional in the
interview because i couldn't stop i
couldn't work at facebook anymore
because what was going on but he wasn't
working for facebook he was a third
dependent third party organization that
moderated so a lot of these guys are
third-party people that are not
necessarily facebook almost all of them
yeah moderators are kind words for
censors
and it's a tough job because you want to
keep child molestation off and direct
threats of violence and so these poor
guys have to
view all this creepy stuff all day
as the supreme court said you know
pornography when you see it that's what
the supreme court said we're talking
about the difference between censorship
well
again you know it when you see it and
and i believe in the supreme court's
ruling but censorship is a whole
different matter well john we we've
we've obviously seen a lot of censorship
and things being taken down regarding
and then yeah every every regarding
vaccines we've seen that right
but they can do it legally but they
can't lie about me well they have every
right to do what
to take down anything they want it's
their discretion yeah their company yeah
that's my they've made it they've made
it very clear that if they don't like
what you're saying about vaccines you're
cut this is the first i've heard about
um global warming though
and you think that's like you're suing
them but at the same time you actually
agree that they can take it down right
but they can't lie about me they they
took it down and they say i said this i
didn't say this we contacted the
reviewers for the sensors he's he's he's
watched it defamation of character
position his position is not a
you can't take the video down
that's the argument that he's making
okay that's hurting his reputation as
somebody that's been doing this for
decades
and because i'm a former
real reporter
when the stuff came out we called them
and said would you talk to me and two of
them agreed to interviews we showed them
the piece and they said well if you
thought we
criticized this because we saw it
no we never watched it
you know what the hell did they make a
public announce did they say anything
did they give you an email did they give
you words did they
write about it somewhere
where we chose to take this down was
there anything that they came back with
to protect your reputation
i'm confused by the who the they is
facebook
no facebook just doesn't respond they
say we leave it to the fact checker
appeal to them and
pass in the
book and letting
the people be their own judge
letting the fact checkers just decide if
they're right or wrong and of course
they say we're right
this piece
doesn't make people
understand
the climate crisis so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you